In ARP, a host queries with an IP address, broadcasting that query
to every other node on the network. That query will be of a form, who has a
particular IP address, such as 130.207.160.47, and
that particular host. Who has that IP
address on the LAN will respond with
the appropriate MAC address. So the ARP query
is a broadcast that goes to every host on the LAN from the host that wants the
answer to the query and the response is
a unicast response with the MAC address as the
answer. That's returned to the host that issued
the query. When the host that issues the query
receives a reply, it starts to build what's
called an ARP table. It's ARP table then maps
each IP address on the local area
network to the corresponding MAC address. Now, instead
of broadcasting a ARP query to discover
the MAC address corresponding with this IP address,
the host can simply consult its local ARP table. Let's now take a look at what
the host does with this information. When the host wants to send a packet to.
The destination with a particular IP address. It takes that IP packet and
encapsulates it in an Ethernet frame
with the corresponding destination MAC address. Essentially,
it puts that IP packet inside of an Ethernet frame. So before it sends
the IP packet with that destination IP address it first puts the packet
inside a larger Ethernet frame with its own source MAC
address and the destination MAC address from its local ARP table.